Speaker 1: So the House commission to investigate
the January six Trump riots is going to kick off
tomorrow. Now, as you might remember, this is
not the commission that was proposed months ago,
which Republicans rejected. This is the new one.
This is the one where Kevin McCarthy, the House
minority leader, selected five Republicans and
Nancy Pelosi said Jim Banks and Jim Jordan can't
be on this committee. They're sort of part of
the problem. They should be maybe witnesses
more than investigators and ultimately Republicans
saying, well, then we won't give you any one. But
Nancy Pelosi inviting Republican Liz Cheney and
Republican Adam Kinzinger to participate. That
kicks off tomorrow. And maybe we will get
some more answers to some of the questions
that remain about exactly what happened on
January 6th. Although the big picture of
what happened is pretty clear. We knew at
the time and it was reported at the time,
Donald Trump seemed to really like what was going
on until there was this moment on January 6th
where Donald Trump was reportedly watching.
And the low class nature, as he saw it, of his
protesters, of the rioters he felt was making him
look bad that Trump reportedly didn't like. But
big picture, Trump seemed pretty pleased with
what was going on. We now have new reporting
from this book. I Alone Can Fix It by Washington
Post reporters Carol Leonnig and Philip Rucker,
where they now are saying Trump was, quote,
almost giddy watching the capital riot on TV.
Carol Leonnig, coauthor of I Alone Can Fix It,
described the scene in an interview with CNN.
Leonnig said Trump was reluctant to call off
the rioters despite urging from daughter Ivanka.
That also relates to a story that we recently
covered. Let's get right into the clip of
Carol Leonnig explaining it herself on CNN
Speaker 2: as the attack on the Capitol is
occurring. What is Trump's state of mind?
What is the feeling inside the White House?
Speaker 3: You know, it's amazing because
we we all lived it, we were in journalism,
but America lived it through TV and he is in his
dining room, off the white, off the Oval Office
watching it and almost giddy because, I mean,
he does watch a lot of TV, but here he is seeing
thousands of his supporters basically trample
up to the steps, break through barricades, all
rallying for him to try to stop the certification
of the election for Joe Biden. And he feels really
supported and emboldened by that. And again,
Kitty, keep in mind that when these people
are, regardless of their intention, when they
are storming the Capitol and going through those
barricades, they're committing a crime.
Speaker 1: Yeah, of course he was.
Of course he was. This really shouldn't be
surprising to anybody. Donald Trump seemed to,
at least for some period of time on January 6th,
believe these people might actually overthrow
the election results, overthrow the government
that is set to be sworn in just two weeks later
and install me as president, which would basically
be becoming a dictator. Right. He he would have
lost, but somehow been installed by force. This
is why he resisted sending in the National Guard
to stop the riots, despite being asked to multiple
times. And we were on a live stream. Many of us
were watching it together wondering, OK, it's one
o'clock, it's two o'clock, it's three o'clock.
Does it really take this long to muster
National Guard? I mean, we know we have the
biggest military and the best everything. And it's
been two hours. And in a situation where clearly
you need people to show up to restore order,
nobody's showing up. Could it really just be
taking this long to get there from Virginia, from
Maryland or wherever the case they were stationed?
And the answer was, of course not. Of course not.
The reason that they didn't show up was because
Donald Trump was resisting sending them. And this
this confirms everything that was being reported
at the time. Even if you look to remember
that first video Trump did, I'm forgetting
the exact timeline. But it might have been five
ish Eastern Time where Trump came out and said
it's time to go home. We love you. Paraphrasing
here, you're justified in your belief about the
election being stolen. The impetus for why you
showed up and rioted, this is my paraphrasing
is a good one. It's an accurate one because it
was really stolen. But as much as we love you,
it's time to go home. Even in that you could tell
Trump was thrilled and Trump was was actually
supportive of the rioters. And so that further
is corroboration. And you have to read the book
to look at the full the full sourcing of it. That
indeed is is more corroboration of what we already
believe to be true. And then lastly, we reported a
few weeks ago that Ivanka Trump and Jared Kushner
are supposedly distancing themselves from Donald
Trump pretty significantly. And Carol Lennix,
additional insights in the book, along with
Philip Rucker, are that Ivanka Trump was
asking Donald Trump as the riots were
unfolding. You've got to stop this, do
something about this. You've got to do something
about it. And Trump refused. And again, if the
reporting that we've seen is to be believed that
indeed Ivanka Trump was not pleased about that,
that would also be coherent with what has already
been reported. None of this is shocking. It just
none of this we don't there's nothing that we're
hearing here where we say, whoa, that's totally
out of character with Trump. That just doesn't
make any sense. No, the impression we got at
the time was that it was because of Trump that
authorities didn't show up more quickly. That's
exactly the reporting that has come out since
then. Our impression at the time from Trump's
weird video was he liked the writers, and that
is now what Philip Rucker and Carol Leonnig are
asserting in their book. I alone can fix it. So
none of it is shocking, but there is more detail
in the book. The one other thing I would say, when
sometimes people write to me, they say, David,
what's the point of this book now at this point?
Well, books take time to write to expect a book
about the Trump riots on January 16th, 10 days
later. It's not it's not reasonable. It takes a
while to write books. And when you're when you're
writing a book and sourcing it, in fact, checking
it in this type of thing, it's going to take some
period of time. There were lots of people who
weren't really paying attention back then to those
reports and they're now hearing this stuff for the
first time. And I do think that that's relevant
as well. I know Trump owns the Republican Party.
Most Republicans just don't care about this or
they won't believe it. But I do think that we're
exposing more people to this reality for the first
time and that is worth it. But just an incredible,
incredible revelation and completely
coherent with what we believed at the time